sometimes it takes a crazy
son-of-a-bitch to mix things up
I don't think Ted Cruz would have done
any of this I don't think Marco Rubio
would have I don't think anyone else
would have done this we're gonna talk
about obviously North Korea President
Donald Trump question of the day what's
your opinion on the North Korea the
summit the outcome are you hopeful for
the first time with this crazy little
bastard or are you disappointed do you
think that we're gonna any good is going
to come of this do you think President
Trump did a good job
I really am curious I would like to see
there seems to be a split on Twitter
it's hard to know comment below here's
what I will say I hate to sound like was
just you know I'm not a hardcore Trumper
okay but um I do think that President
Trump is making some concessions here
because Kim Jong knows that if he
doesn't get in gear Trump's gonna he
will without a doubt drop the hammer I
can't picture a world in which he
wouldn't drop the hammer on him and
we'll get into why I think that is this
is obviously the topic everyone's been
talking about listen when I said those
things when I said those damn things
when I went back home I got so rebuilt
rest I guess nobody dumped me I was
sitting up protecting everything and I
believe it our Korea everything why
would you why would you believe in North
Korea yeah not super articulate but I
didn't have the best interviewer and no
the DNC pool boy in chief Chris Cuomo we
actually have we're actually the only
show we have exclusive access to his
brain ship microphone every blessed 30
days okay how much time's left here two
minutes three minutes okay Chris you can
hold it for three minutes nope nope
can't do three minutes wait what's he
saying
oh wait is he the one with the AIDS Oh
[Music]
historic day so happy he's so happy I'm
happy for you Chris I'm happy that you
were able to actuate your fecal
assimilation here's what I'm saying on
ego alone
let alone policy if Kim Zhang
embarrasses president Trump are lying
because right now there's a lot of
conjecture we don't know what's out
there exactly we don't know what he's
going to stick to as we never do with
Kim Jong but can you imagine any world
where Kim Jong embarrasses president
Donald Trump on the national stage and
doesn't get crap hammered look what he
did with Canada right look what he did
with Canada the tariffs and I'm not a
fan necessarily of the tariffs yeah but
he did this because he got pissed
comments no I have a good relationship
with Justin Trudeau I really did other
than he had a news conference that he
had because he assumed I was in an
aeroplane and I wasn't watching learn
that's gonna cost a lot of money for the
people he really kind of stabbed us in
the back
oh really actually you know what he did
a great disservice to the whole g7 he'd
betray heard oh did yes he did
POTUS is not gonna let a Canadian Prime
Minister push him around push him told
us around President Trump well that guy
just seemed a little bit needlessly
passionate about it but it's not a big
fan of the tariffs obviously but I'm not
a big fan of the way Canada's been
engaging necessarily in international
trade I'm not a big fan of Justin
Trudeau okay but I do love how caddy is
it it and maybe next time okay maybe
next time you'll lift the toilet seat
baby baby baby huh how's the 35% tariff
I'd steal maybe next time you lifted I
don't have to fall in at night um I
think isn't it some contrast longer
because everyone's upset now with a
president Trump complimenting Kim Jong
by the way for good I don't think Kim
Jong moon is worthy of any compliment so
let's be fair here I really wish that
President Trump hadn't done this but I
do think the wise interesting well he is
very talented anybody that takes over a
situation like he did at 26 years of age
and is able to run it he's run a tie
kim jongseo some great Legos to make
most magnificent of Legos Kim strong
doesn't blame it didn't say it's like
he's a talented I don't think he buys I
really wish the president repent guy
yeah he hasn't done anything impressive
at all in his life Kim jong-un has done
zero impressive his entire life but like
you said na ki dude why is he
complimenting him because I do think
with a crazy person like that who
surrounded by psycho fancy kinda need to
make him think that he's one contrast
that with President Obama who who tried
to talk semi tough and accomplished
absolutely zero on the other hand when
North Korea tests a bomb that endangers
all of us in any country that breaks
this basic bargain must face increased
and those nations wid these weapons like
the United States have a unique
responsibility to pursue the path of
reducing our stockpots why by affirming
basic norms like the commitment to never
test them again shoulder to shoulder
both in the face of provocations and in
our refusal to accept any nuclear Korea
North Korea I threat swill get North
Korea nothing other than greater
isolation how do you get a greater
isolate like he sent the Buehler guy
there to threaten somebody I don't
understand this it's like we have we've
been at peace for decades and no one has
attacked us when you look at our nuclear
arsenal I don't understand it why would
we reduce our stockpile it's never gonna
happen why do you get to keep them
because we're the good guys it's true
because we're not starving our own
people down so yeah in this situation
you know there's a lot of a lot of
people on the left are coming back and
saying that he's giving concessions he's
doing stuff he's stupid for doing this
there's no agreement we need a
relationship they're not a relationship
of a friendship we need somebody who's
willing to come to the table and Trump
accomplish that when no other president
has done it right none so if you want a
bad map but we didn't get results it's
kind of like telling a first date like I
don't think I'm gonna be very productive
on the first day yeah exactly sit out
everyone's flaw all the flaws
the person like and and first of all I
think you should we don't the civil
rights issues are important I think we
should get to that eventually North
Korea but that's not the most important
issue when it comes to our national
security now right they go I've seen
that you're not gonna you're not gonna
fix that with this meeting but let's
give you a quick quick timeline okay
North Korea they've never gotten it
right US policy is never worked in 1994
Bill Clinton North Korea sign an
agreement no okay they didn't do it
Bush administration in 2002-2003 they
reactivated then we go to 2007 there was
talks to resume North Korea again I
think we haven't reached 2012 weeks
after Kim reaches a deal to suspend its
nuclear weapons program they long to
launch a long-range rocket so here's the
thing with President Trump is he a
narcissist of course all the president
criticisms about his personality are
true but on policy he tends to keep his
promises he lowered taxes he pulls out
of the Iran deal great precedent set
here the Paris climate agreement he
moved the embassy to Jerusalem we got
Korsak as a as a judge regulations are
being slashed vs. President Obama who
did not close Gitmo he did not manage to
lower premiums with health care for
families he failed to allow imports of
cheaper foreign for arsenals he didn't
in in the income tax for seniors making
less than $50,000 and he also failed in
the war in Afghanistan and Iraq his
foreign policy was absolutely abysmal
the point that I'm making here is that
any kind of deal which occurred under
present Obama wasn't worth the paper it
was printed on as a matter of fact the
risk of any deal with the crazy tyrants
surrounded by sycophants like they only
speak one language someone like Kim Jong
that's the language of action and based
on the track record if even for the very
same valid reasons people criticize
Donald Trump this is I'm not I'm not
saying that this is this is a the best
deal we could get I'm saying I'm looking
at this a little optimistically there's
a lot this is entirely opinion for the
same reasons people criticize Trump that
he's trigger-happy
that he punishes people based on ego
camera Donald is singing a different
tune because of that the language that
he speaks is ego and humiliation and I
think President Trump right now is
giving him something to lose by
complimenting him saying he's talented
and guess what he can take that all the
way that would sting Kim jong-eun a
whole lot more than a war that I think
he wants anyway so I'm not saying that
this is all good news I am saying
sometimes crazy people can spot other
crazy people and then it just comes down
to who can out crazy the other person
first you take this right out of the
blue plant a blueprint of Reagan dealing
with Russia right you had to show
strength to make sure that these guys
were gonna come to the table and
actually be good faith actors right
hopefully that's what this leads to with
him he's had to see somebody on the
other side that was willing to kick his
butt was the first person willing became
a big difference between ourselves Trump
first got prisoners released Trump then
also got them to stop testing then he's
gonna walk away from the meeting
remember and he pulled out this is just
such a terrible mistake and then he came
back to the table they came back to the
table also by the way Trump's got in
shine involved this time around they're
the ones you can put some real economic
pressure on North Korea that's a big
deal so he approached the table very
differently I'm not the kind of person
saying he's playing he's throwing seven
different kinds of smoke he's playing an
18 D chess no no but in this case he is
taking a different approach and he's a
very different the kind of personality
that makes other crazy people nervous
kim jong doesn't want to be on the on
the negative side of it doesn't wanna be
that's the thing so you praise him a
little bit like ha man I saw what he did
with yeah we're gonna say fan you don't
you have a different opinion I think
nothing is going to happen here beep
beep I think this is just another
agreement where North Korea is just
signing off on the paper that means
nothing to them and then they will break
it and then instead Trump will do
nothing because Ivanka will storm into
the White House and say that please
don't hurt them
and then john bolton will also rush in
and say nuke them and then from we're
just not ready okay she says go touch
him he says Nukem how would I just go
and take advantage we would break it off
is that a fair battle ground here's the
thing I wouldn't put it past Donald
Trump to actually try to kill Kim Jong I
really wouldn't maybe look look at he
does but look at looking around looking
gorsek when the tax cuts the tariffs
that's a huge deal so I hate to say this
and this is one thing with President
Donald Trump I I am willing to admit
that we were wrong when it comes to the
election and a lot in a lot of ways
sometimes it takes a crazy
son-of-a-bitch to mix things up I don't
think Ted Cruz would have done any of
this I don't think Marco Rubio would
have I don't think anyone else
done this sometimes it takes a guy to
out-crazy the other crazy got Churchill
one of the greatest leaders ever by the
way he was a drunken people thought he
was crazy
sometimes you need crazy people to do
crazy things
he's a crazy mother sometimes but he's
ours let me give you an example this is
kind of what Donald Trump is okay I had
a friend who was a cop
all right told me this story he was
apprehending some gang members okay
they had been dealing drugs yeah
separating some gang members they you
know they'd scattered so one of them
this is true all right you have a bar
fight you're happening get one of them
crapped himself covered himself in his
own crap took a bunch of PCP and said
all right Oh once again was running
around at the car and my friend was the
one who had to grab him and tackle him
to the ground here the thing that guy
got caught but some other guys got away
and sometimes we need a president when
everyone's out there fighting and
running people through the bar and
breaking pool cues you need president
Donald Trump good all right who wants
some of this cabbage ah no he sometimes
a crazy son of a [ __ ] when you've been
dealing with crazy sons of [ __ ]
across the ocean this entire time and
what we've done hasn't worked at all I
don't if only because it's a different
tact and I think the main criticisms
logged against Trump could play in his
favor here you let me know usually this
is the point where I would tell you to
subscribe or hit the notification bell
up there because subscriptions don't
mean a whole lot on YouTube but if
you've been signed up now at lotto with
credit calm slash mug Club for all the
daily content to support us there's
probably there's not a pitch I can make
here that'll work so let me just tell
you this I have a cat in my basement
right now if you don't subscribe at
lotto with creditor com / mug Club to
support this content I am going to kill
him if you don't subscribe this cat in
my basement will die